"Середньостатистичний робітник у Німеччині за 17 днів виробляє стільки ж,
скільки середньостатистичний робітник в Україні за один рік".
Це фрагмент із доповіді Світового банку про перспективи економічного розвитку України,
і це відверто шокує.
Невже українці настільки погано працюють?
Для економістів будь-яка ефективність, зрозуміло, виміріюється грішми.
В даному разі сумою, на яку виробляє товарів, послуг або інших благ
середньостатистичний працівник.
І якщо скористатися даними того ж Світового банку,
Організації економічного співробітництва та розвитку(ОЕСР),
Євростату та українського Мінекономрозвитку, виходить, що умовний Петро
за годину праці збагачує Україну приблизно на 3-4 долари.
Умовний Петер - Німеччину – на 72. Пьотр - Польщу – на 38 з половиною.
А їхній товариш з Китаю - свою державу - приблизно на 15 доларів.
Отже, Петрові, щоби рухати економіку вперед, доведеться працювати значно більше, ніж Петерові
та й навіть китайському товаришеві.
Хоча Петро і так працює багато:
економісти підрахували, що українець працює в середньому 1990 годин на рік,
тоді як німець - лише 1336.
То в чому ж - проблема українців?
Видовищні офіційні ролики позиціонують Україну - як державу з якісною робочою силою.
Кваліфікованою та освіченою: "майже стовідсоткова грамотність,
четверта найосвіченіша нація в світі, 640 тисяч випускників університетів у рік".
Утім, як зауважують і європейські експерти, і українські бізнесмени,
якість цієї освіти залишає бажати кращого.
Гонитва за університетськими дипломами продукує армію не надто конкурентоспроможних робітників.
І як наслідок - не сприяє зростанню зарплат.
Середній заробіток, за офіційними даними, в Україні у 2018 році ледь перевищив 300 доларів.
У Німеччині понад 300 професій можна здобути без університетського диплому.
Відбувається це у профтехучилищах за так званою дуальною системою:
два дні теорії і три дні практики на підприємствах.
Студенти отримують стипендію і зарплату.
Найвищий заробіток - в учнів пивоварів та фахівців з мехатроніки - тисяча-півтори тисячі євро на місяць.
Найнижчі - в учнів у салонах краси - кількасот євро.
Проблема безробіття випускникам з профосвітою в Німеччині не загрожує,
а підприємства ще й вкладають чималі кошти у постійне підвищення кваліфікації.
Продуктивність німецькі компанії підвищують не лише за рахунок персоналу:
вони дедалі більше використовують штучний інтелект.
Так, лише в обробній промисловості ФРН кожен четвертий верстат уже нині підключений до інтернету.
А серед найбажаніших якостей працівників німецькі бізнесмени називають цифрову компетенцію.
В Україні ж, за даними Світового банку, вкладення в працівника –
зокрема й витрати на перекваліфікацію й технічне переоснащення – залишаються на рівні пізніх 90-х.
Серед факторів, які заважають підвищенню продуктивності праці в Україні -
і загальний низький рівень інвестицій, кажуть економісти.
На відміну від тієї ж Німеччині, де бізнесмени можуть розраховувати
на незалежну судову систему і стабільне законодавство,
від України їх досі відлякують корупція та незавершені реформи,
зокрема судова і земельна, а також непрозорість в енергетиці та фінансах.
Держава в Україні все ще надто впливає на процеси в економіці, що також стримує капіталовкладення.
За такою логікою, ситуація в Китаї могла би бути ще гіршою,
однак там продуктивність праці - значно вища, і зростання зарплат триває кілька років поспіль.
Чому так? Не в останню чергу - завдяки роботизації виробництва та підвищенню кваліфікції працівників.
80% валютних надходжень країна отримує від експорту.
Найбільш конкурентна її продукція наразі -
одяг, взуття, іграшки, телекомунікаційне обладнання та електроніка.
Україна ж тим часом спирається на сировинний експорт -
переважно аграрний та металургійний -
галузі з високою ціновою нестабільністю та невисокою доданою вартістю.
На цьому, зауважують у Світовому банку, економічного дива не побудуєш.
Якщо конкретніше, за акутальних темпів економічного зростання
Україні знадобиться понад 50 років, щоби наздогнати нинішню Польщу.
Із поточним борговим навантаженням і низьким темпом реформ зробити це буде важко.
Польща тим часом демонструє небувале зростання ефективності праці -
разом з Румунією, Латвією та Болгарією.
Причина, кажуть економісти - адекватна реакція на трудову міграцію.
Оскільки ці країни в останні роки зіштовхнутися із різким відтоком робочої сили,
тамтешній бізнес був змушений підвищувати ефективність праці тих, хто залишився.
Чи зможе цим рецептом скористатись Україна? Відкрите питання.
Отже, це тільки на перший погляд працювати продуктивніше - це працювати більше і важче.
Насправді це зовсім не так.
Наступним завданням перед найпродуктивнішими країнами
буде вже не як працювати менше і виробляти більше,
а як працювати ефективніше і менше шкодити довкіллю.
А для України? Все ще - як наздогнати Польщу?